- We're getting a couple
questions about being a speaker.
So Esteban saying, how do I
start becoming a paid speaker?
(mumbles) is asking, how
do you evaluate speakers
who are coming in?
So, in terms of being a speaker,
you do a lot of speaking,
obviously, as part of what you do.
You've hired speakers to come
in and speak at your events.
What are your thoughts on people
getting into the paid speaking business
and their evolution
advice to help them out?
- Yeah, I think the parasocial
is really incredible here,
so I think if you want
to become a paid speaker,
I think it's fantastic, and obviously
it could be pretty lucrative.
Um, again, I think, number
one, you need to have,
in this case, the product is you.
So you are the product.
So what's your idea?
What's your point of view?
What do you want to be famous for?
And it could be, you know, you've done,
like Evan talks a lot,
and he goes to speak
in conferences about entrepreneurship,
and he's now famous for that.
He's a brand.
And I think, you know,
what is your number one?
What is your product?
What is your big idea?
It's you.
What's your point of view?
And then the next question to ask yourself
is why are you different?
How do you differentiate yourself?
Because, again, it's
a crowded marketplace,
it's a noisy marketplace.
You want to be different.
And then I think once you determine that,
then you've got to build your profile.
The great news about social
is the audience can come to you.
So, you know, if you're
talking about women in business
or you're talking about inclusion
or you're talking about breaking through
the glass ceiling, whatever
it is, or exporting
in terms of what are the lessons learned,
if you're a U.S. business
and you want to export
to Europe and Asia, whatever it is,
you will find something where ...
The good news is there
will be thousands of people
out there who will want
to hear your story again.
And then when you do speak,
and I'll say it kind of
how do you amplify the
message, and we've talked
about this before in
(mumbles) around social media.
I think that's a brilliant
way to build a following,
build a brand, build your fame,
and the audience will come.
And then, you know,
you get things like DMs
where people pop up and say
we'd like you to come and speak
at this conference, and
I think with these things
you should kind of test-drive it.
What I'd advise then is develop
some really compelling stories.
And again, when you do stand up there,
you want to tell them most of all
the authentic, tell them
your story, and again,
put yourself, in sort of what we said,
put yourself in the shoes of the audience.
And obviously, if it's a big
conference of 2,000 people
or 200 people, or even 20 people,
you want to kind of think,
how do I make this really
interesting for the audience?
What is likely to be on their mind?
And what parts of my story
are going to kind of jump out
for them and make this memorable?
Because again, the amazing thing is
we probably all go to conferences.
Evan, you must have gone to
thousands of conferences.
The question you ask yourself ...
How do you become memorable?
How do people talk about your
story that you presented?
And they share that with your friends
and then you have a moment,
you have a following.
And literally, I know
the case I quote about
someone I went to see speak 10 years ago,
and they blew me away.
And that could be you.
So I think, I do think
it starts at the basics
about the kind of big idea, the product,
the product is you, build
your social media following,
have a strong point of
view, and you will find then
that you will get booked on,
and you can do stuff,
I'm not a big fan of it,
and I think it's likely
to be disintermediated,
(audio skips) speaker marketing agencies
that kind of book speakers
and they take a commission
and all that sort of stuff.
And a lot of famous
people and celebrities,
use through their agents, these
speaker marketing agencies,
but I think the way the reality
of the social media world
has sort of changed that forever.
But what you might want
to do, when you get a bit
of a following, if you did
want to do something around
engaging an agent and one of these sort of
speaker marketing agencies,
there's plenty of them.
If you go to Toronto,
there's probably a dozen
speaker marketing agencies there,
in New York, they're all over the place.
But again, they will
have the way they do it.
Companies like us,
we're doing Sage Summit,
we want to book a speaker,
we want him talking about
maybe general entrepreneurship
or how to overcome adversity
or exporting or how do you
get ready to grow and scale
your business from being
a startup to scaleup.
Whatever the theme is,
they'll go down the playbook
of who we got on the books.
It's almost like an actor sort of agent.
They've got, who's got
these sort of skills,
who can address this,
and then they'll book you in there.
I think, because this is very personal,
and the product is you, I
think you should take control
of that, and I'm always,
my advice would always ...
I'm very reticent ... for you to sort of,
this is a bad word, but sort
of prostitute your brand
out there with lots of different
people so they dilute you.
I think you want to be true to yourself,
be congruent, be authentic, and be you.
And then people will come to love you.
If you've got a compelling
idea, a big vision,
and you tell it in a great story.
Wow, you will make yourself memorable.
- I think to Steven's point,
the gatekeepers are disappearing.
Those people who you
have to go through them
to get any opportunities, is disappearing.
Those speaker houses,
the people who you need
their approval to get anything done,
it's going away, which
creates a lot of opportunity
for a lot of people,
but you have to be good.
And you get good by practicing.
You've got to practice.
If you want to be a speaker, I
would be on YouTube everyday,
practicing your speech,
practicing answering questions.
Practicing, practicing,
practicing, practicing.
Your talent should be obvious.
There's this great clip that we included
on one of our videos
of Eminem, the rapper,
prank calling a radio station.
He said his name was
like, I'm John from Miami,
something like that, and he
said, hey can I rap for you?
And he did some wrap, and LL
Cool J was on the station,
and DJs were on the
station, and they said man
you're really good,
like you should consider
doing this as a career, John from Miami.
And they didn't know it was Eminem,
and later on he said it was Eminem,
and he pulled their leg, and the thing is
like his talent was obvious.
So is your talent obvious.
Steven talked about he
went to go see a speaker
10 years ago that like blew him away.
Are you doing that to your audiences?
If you make a YouTube video
and the people who watch it
are blown away, they're going to share it.
They're going to tell
their friends about it.
You're going to get
booked on speaker gigs.
And the more you do that,
the more content you create
that blows people away,
the more your profile
is going to rise.
The challenge is for most people,
you're not quite good enough yet.
You need to practice more.
You've got to get to that point
where you can blow people away.
Since the market is so wide open,
you've got people around the world now
you're competing with that
you have to get really good.
And so it's never been
easier, which is great,
but you have to put in
the work to get there,
and so I would be starting a
YouTube channel immediately.
I would be posting daily
content, work work work.
I was not a great speaker when I started,
but I did 4,000 YouTube videos, right?
You better get better after
doing something 4,000 times.
Anything.
If you're practicing basketball,
if you take 4,000 shots,
you better get better at taking that shot.
It's hard not to.
And so I think getting
out there and practicing
so that when people see
you, they are blown away,
is going to be your ticket in,
much more than trying to go to an agency
or these houses, because the
gatekeepers are going away.
To Steven's point.
I agree.